tonight I have signed an executive order
initiating a military quarantine of New
York City borders are closed and flights
have been grounded stranding millions of
travelers we have lost all contact with
the outer extremities as the Dow Jones
Industrial Average fell over 2000 points
and it's worse
[Music]
this is like the end of capitalism this
is like the Dark Ages all over again
then I wake up today and ask for the
wake up from well loosen eight NorAm
okay June I've got some bad news what
else is left but to abandon even the
hope of truth and content ourselves
instead with stories can you look me in
the eye and tell me you've got this
under control
and it's not gonna end up in a disaster
yes how many dead no no there aren't any
numbers yet what do you think it is now
we call that number
the are not distance silver has it
default numbers are huge what does the
dissimilar to say three point six
rongkhun but that's as high as that
makes three point six not great or
terrible hey buddy what temperature you
got ninety eight point six wait a minute
is this thing broken again
our sources number the data as low as 10
as high as 50 I think the true number is
much much higher it was at that moment
the mark bomb realized the whole world
economy might collapse what are you
doing we have to shut all the way down
not maybe we should put the city on full
alert no such thing I don't want to bust
up your party sir but you got to issue
an alert you bring me in to tell me
everything's fine and everything's NOT
fine but I've been assured there is no
problem I'm telling you that there is I
prefer my opinions of yours seek we're
not getting sick we have far too much
planned Amity is a summer town
we need summer dollars what it's the
biggest shopping weekend of the year I
think we need to consider closing
schools down now if you fellas are
concerned about the beaches you do
whatever you have to to make them safe
but those beaches will be open for this
weekend and right from the beginning you
knew this was different because it was
happening in small villages market towns
mobile regardless we have a protocol for
scenarios like that isolating everybody
I've already quarantined the Boston med
staff EMS crew so girls neighbors why am
I in here gonna have to go into
quarantine that's it so we there's
nothing else I can do just wait
well I just happens to be exactly what
I'm looking for I'm I'm outlining a new
writing project and five months of peace
is just what I want - four weeks
imma raid the minibar sit back and watch
my Niners in the Superbowl about your
wife and son how do you think they'll
take to it they'll love it
my wife is here do you think I would
keep it in Pripyat if he wasn't safe by
the time they tried to evacuate the
cities it was already too late the
infection was everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
how things going mr. turrets things
could be better Lloyd things could be a
whole lot better says here only eight
weeks well that's not long enough for
guys to go bunkers [ __ ] boy five
minutes is enough to put a man over down
here you spent weeks ago since we've mr.
Winslow was supposed to be here for two
months it's been eight months I mean
this is logic same funny
no dink and I ain't want to be stranded
here with some damage I can't take it
anymore your honor please I'm much
better
and I won't harm anybody you got to let
me come back inside
but the government what do they do
it's no government course is a
government
[Music]
you wanna hate about banking it reduces
people to numbers here's a number every
1% unemployment goes up 40,000 people
die did you know that these are not
statistics ladies and gentlemen their
fortune blood and I want you to burn
those into your memories
[Music]
you knew there was a shark out there you
knew it was dangerous anyway I got
people to dr. Cheever we all do I don't
think it wanted anything
it wasn't destroying it was changing
everything he was making something new
well she's got a dad and he's greats
daughter so I was wrong when I said
they're staying in life is as good as it
gets I think despite the stupidity the
lies from this you're compelled problem
has been assigned and you'll stop at
nothing until you find an answer Neville
it's working
it's what we either have a high chance
of killing one person or a low chance of
killing six people or how do we make
that decision we this spring we lose
summer with use another 144 days that
don't happen again
if we do everything perfectly we had 533
days to our mission you'll do it because
it must be done if you don't millions
will die if you tell me that's not
enough I won't believe you Jules what do
you think you're doing
save and Frank we do why don't we just
wait here for a little while
see what happens
otter family do you think they're
infected
[Music]